men between the ages of 18 and 30 on
average pay 2 000 a year of video games
at least fifty percent of them are doing
it whilst on prescription mats or on
let's say that there are two versions of
the world one in which the traditional
young male syndrome of populist
uprisings and dangerous men and stuff
occurs and the other one in which you've
got my sedation hypothesis going on
given the choice between the two I would
rather have men not be causing havoc and
burning down buildings but only by a
little bit you have got an army of
useless sedated men who are not
contributing to society they're not
working jobs they're not innovating
they're not driving GDP every year that
they continue to do the things that
they're doing playing video games whilst
they become less and less of an
attractive mate for the sort of partner
that would drag them out of that in any
case you have a choice here between men
who are dangerous but competent or
sedated but useless yeah tough choices